in my mind i want to be able to say if
you are here i will serve you whatever
you need we will make it happen but
that's not the truth the truth is
budgets are
filled by enrollment
in michigan's capital city the lansing
school district's student count had been
shrinking for years but prior to the
pandemic those losses were leveling out
then last year as students parents and
their schools struggled to stay
connected during the pandemic the
district experienced a drop of almost a
thousand students from the year prior a
9.2 decrease
we count on the walls of schools so
heavily
and the walls kind of like keep us
gathered in like this one central
location and we did not have that
over the past year and a half that
worrisome trend played out in public
school districts nationwide last year
and this fall it's unclear how many of
those students will return
this upcoming school year is new for
everyone it's it's pivotal there's no
question about that so what's at stake
for schools long term if they can't
recover student numbers lost during the
pandemic
traditionally public school enrollment
and school funding are linked as a
school has more students enrolled they
get more funding from the state
when it comes to that state funding
enrollment in michigan is normally
evaluated on two count days during the
school year which means regular student
attendance is crucial during the
pandemic many states including michigan
eased restrictions around how students
are counted
this helped to limit reductions in
per-pupil state aid
another safety net funding from the
kovid 19 relief law
in 2020 the lansing school district
received 8 227 dollars per student in
state aid which initially meant
approximately 84 million dollars in
state funding
without those more flexible policies the
district says last year's student count
decline could have resulted in a loss of
around six million dollars
this year student counts are largely
returning to pre-pandemic policies
if schools aren't able to bring enough
students back to school they will be
forced to deal with some rather
significant and awful decisions to make
whether it's cuts to personnel
programming cuts those are all closely
tied to the amount of students they have
enrolled
enrollment declines don't necessarily
mean a school's costs go down so when
budgets are cut it often means schools
are left with less money to pay for the
staffing and programs that the school
still needs nationally grades that saw
the most significant drop-offs were
kindergarten and pre-k grades that are
not compulsory in many states that
enrollment trend also occurred in
lansing families just didn't enroll
their children and so they were just
waiting out for another year they
basically red-shirted their kids experts
say they initially believed enrollment
in younger students would tick up this
fall and that kindergarten classes might
even be overcrowded but the spread of
the delta variant is throwing that into
question
this is jacia murphy i'm the principal
at rio elementary how are you do you
know what the first day of school is
i am talking to
teachers and i'm talking to parents what
do we do to keep these kids in school
simply put
of the students who officially left rio
last year murphy says the reasons for
those departures varied
some moved away others shifted to
schools offering in-person learning
i lost parents
because they
needed students in the classroom i lost
students to
charter schools within the lansing
school district boundary as a parent i
always left those conversations saying i
get it
i get it
murphy says the larger issue at rio
where 87 percent of kids are eligible
for free or reduced lunch was with
families who disengaged or burned out
from virtual learning i would say our
preschool kids and our kindergarten kids
disengaged early on in the school year
and it was easier for those parents
because i asked it was easier for those
parents to say we'll see you when we can
come in person
this fall is the first time the lansing
school district is welcoming students
back in person
schuldener and his team put together
different budgets based on potential
enrollment numbers because the
district's budget won't be finalized for
this school year until after the fall
student count which takes place in
october i've got some doomsday budgets
about what it looks like at 8 000 kids
and that was about
are you going to shut a school down are
you going to close some programs are you
going to do certain things and then i
have some you know wonderful rainbow in
the sky kind of things that at 11 000
wow we might be able to reopen some
programs that we had shuttered 20 years
ago so how are public schools working to
recover students schuldener outlined
three enrollment initiatives that
lansing is prioritizing first and
foremost is that we've announced
universal pre-k that for me is a
linchpin to what a district should
always be doing schuldener hopes it
improves enrollment in the long term we
looked at some numbers and we basically
said wow the students that start with us
in pre-k stay with us
second the district created a k-12
online school for anyone who prefers
remote instruction
the online school will also allow the
district some flexibility so that kids
enrolled in in-person instruction who
need to quarantine because of covid19
can continue to attend school and still
be counted
the third enrollment initiative focuses
on outreach to the community
instead of them coming to us we're
pushing out because we're trying to get
enrollment numbers up and create new
relationships
we got
for anybody from k-12 for any of the
lansing public schools so make sure you
see that booth
i will never be unprepared
to enroll a student
you don't have to come to me i will find
you
so if i'm at the grocery store and i see
little kid i'm like hey how old are you
what school you go to
murphy says she and her team are working
to solve problems for families and
answer questions that might be
preventing parents from bringing
students back to school do you need
transportation
do you need before or after care
i don't think so okay i think you're all
good
once the academic year begins school
leaders like murphy need to ensure that
those students who did enroll keep
showing up schools need to be really
hyper focused on the supports that they
provide to educators as those educators
then provide supports to students as
they return back to the classrooms
that return looks increasingly
complicated as districts around the
country face challenges like staffing
shortages and quarantines due to the
spread of covid19
lansing school district has implemented
a mask mandate for anyone entering
district buildings and a vaccine
requirement for staff
still scholdener says without renewed
policies that allow for more flexibility
attendance and student counts may be
threatened by quarantines or school
closures due to covid19 so if that means
i need to have conversations with
parents about
why their enrollment matters to us
collectively at rio i need to get my
talking points together and make sure
that that is communicated in a kind
sensitive way but one that is effective
and resonates with all of us
because we do need all of us in order
for this to work